if you want to go from the very
beginning from day one of judo class to
olympic
champion
or olympic medalist
what does it take
to become an olympic medalist in judo
from start to finish
like how many different trajectories do
you see or is there some
unifying principles
i think a lot of it has to your journey
is going to depend a lot by where you're
from
so a path that an american might take
versus somebody who's from japan or
somebody who's from europe there's two
very just three very distinct paths
right
because
you know in japan it's part of the
culture it's it there's a there's a
system of excellence there's you know
there's elementary school judo there's
junior high school there's high school
there's collegiate there's olympic and
you know
much like our wrestling is here in our
in the united states right it's very
similar there's youth wrestling there's
high school this ncaa and then there's
olympic wrestling and you know when you
when you your country is a factory of
producing athletes at the highest level
then all of those top athletes typically
go back into the sport and there's
professions for them they have an
opportunity to coach at all those
different levels and just the level of
their game and the expertise that all of
them have even down at the elementary
level make their skill
so solid and as a coach in that
situation you can just sit back
and watch who stands out
as opposed to i think in america i guess
you need to
craft
you don't get to choose from a thousand
people a few people that naturally stand
out at the age of nine
you get you have to actually
uh
whatever the natural resources you're
given
craft them into a champion
um
so if we look at that the american way
where you just have a person with a
smile show up show up to your dojo says
i wanted to be an olympic medalist
what process do you take them through
well the odds are really insurmountable
like it's it's a very very high hill to
climb and there's only a few i there's
only a few people and there's only a few
coaches in this entire country that
really understand that process
and they can that can help people reach
that level
as as it's been proven right yeah um
number one you you certainly have to
have a solid base a fundamental base of
of an expectation of what the training
is going to be
and it has to be a level of
professionalism very very early where
you're teaching all the basic judo moves
all the basic fundamental movements
posture
gripping um well maybe gripping doesn't
come in so early in the game but
throwing methodology movements nawaza
position
um standing fundamental throws and i
think most importantly is really the
work ethic just the way you're going to
train the intensity you're going to
train with the ability to
you know mindset of going to tournaments
constantly you need you know in order to
compete with the rest of the world
our young kids need to
be tested
a lot when they're young they have to be
put through adversity because they don't
get put through adversity and training
because you don't have that many good
training partners so you get put through
adversity in competition and then do we
see what your weaknesses are and we
continue to make improvements on those
but the journey is is
it's long and and until they're kind of
at the teenage years they're going to
have to pretty much stay domestic right
because they got to go through life as a
normal kid but they've got to be
training in the dojo at least you know
five days a week
you know sometimes they might want to
get you know an extra technical workout
in or doing some base conditioning in
addition to that and then really at the
teenage years that's where we really um
we've struggled in america of of keeping
teens in the sport of judo as well as
developing them properly because up
until around the teenage years i think
the americans are on par with the rest
of the world in terms of technique and
in terms of skill and in
you know we've we've proven we can
compete with the rest of the world up
until that age but
that's where japan and that's where the
europeans and the the countries that are
strong in judo that's where they put a
lot of time energy and effort is into
the teens
where they have a great coaching staff
they have good training camps with with
800 a thousand people going to them
every single weekend
um when you say teens what do you mean
do you mean literally like 13 yeah
13 to 17 13 to 19. and that's where sort
of that's when you really accelerate
your development so you're saying like
in america when you're young
like before you know
9 10 11 12 you stick in judo you can
progress quite a bit right but then i
guess the other competition there
if you're into uh
two people uh
you know doing stuff to each other in a
combative way
uh the other competitor in america is
wrestling
so judo almost primes you like it
teaches you uh how to be a great
wrestler as well and so then you have to
have a hard decision
because you can probably be a collegiate
wrestler
you can you can you have like a a clear
plan
of where you're going to go if you want
to be a wrestler where judo
that plan is more um
it is less clear
so yeah you have to be on your own a bit
with your coach that kind of thing
exactly
okay so when you're on your own with
your coach to me that's just a
fascinating journey because it then is
just like the purity of it it's the
coach and the athlete and the dream
it's all about the dedication the the
five six seven days a week
competing what once a month
twice a month
okay and just but also you probably
don't have that conversation i don't
know if you do maybe you do
saying like we're gonna do this for the
next eight years
right
do you ever sit down would you just do
it take it to david goggins way which is
like let's just take it one step at a
time
let's hope we're there in eight years
yeah let's hope we're there do you like
actually like right now you have to
think about
the olympics is going to be in in los
angeles in 2028 so it's really
interesting now now would be the time
and now is the time
to identify talent
and get commitment out of students that
in seven years you can make a u.s
olympic team because we're going to have
a full team
america is going to have 14 athletes
compete in those games one in every
weight class so now is the time if
you're going to go on a journey to the
olympics and stay with the sport of judo
now would be the time to do it
you know and so what uh
you show up to the pedro judo center
and
how much drilling how much
technique strategy discussions how much
randori or like live sparring how much
conditioning and strength
training
how much of all that
how much of cross training to other gyms
or something like that so traveling
abroad is there something to be said
about us um some aspects of that system
for sure um you need it all what you
just said we needed all of it and we do
do all of that right now we have a young
group of kids at the academy you'll see
tonight some of them are 14 13 15 17.
are they good yeah really good okay so
they're going to get away they're right
around your weight so it'll be perfect
[Laughter]
they're just young boys but they've been
training hard through kovid yeah um
we've been travis and myself have been
training them we share responsibilities
um they're doing randori like five
nights a week you know we have them
doing randori tuesdays
wednesdays uh thursdays fridays and
sundays is when they're doing randori
they're coming to the dojo friday night
and sunday night to do training
um
we also have technical sessions for them
and they're in school now so it's a
little bit challenging but they come
five o'clock in the afternoon and they
do a technical session through covert
they were coming every morning doing
technical sessions what's the technical
session you're it's an hour of um
repetitive throwing or repetitive
drilling to to reinforce movements that
we deem important to our successful uh
system so nawaza positions groundwork
positions where we want them to be put
in this position and they're going to
drill it 50 times you know with
resistance in big groups you know doing
drills over and over again picking apart
the details of the technique and what
they're doing wrong showing them how to
fix it but now we've done it so much
that now we can do a whole drill session
with them where they know all the
different techniques inside and out and
they can move from position to position
really quickly do they do it for a
period of time like two minutes five
minutes or is it like one two they're
actually counting no
sometimes it's both so sometimes we do
it for reps sometimes we do it for time
yeah and so sometimes it might be as
many as they can do in in 60 seconds or
as many as they can do in two minutes
and sometimes it might just be i want
you to do every position five times
in terms of throws
we're not talking about on a crash pad
right it's it's just we're talking about
free moving around the mat and just
dynamically and just throwing correct
you